[Music]
china
has been anal swabbing us diplomats
[Music]
that's that's an act of aggression right
they said it was a mistake come on bro
yeah they
bent us over and they [ __ ] penetrated
us yeah i think they're just [ __ ]
with us at this point
i think they're just [ __ ] with
they're just and then they said oops oh
my bad clinical error like they make
errors like
yeah they never admit to fault right
even with corona they're like nah we did
everything right
and when it comes to bending us over and
shoving [ __ ] in our ass
all of a sudden it's an error no error
with corona not a single thing they did
wrong with corona
right everything perfectly done right
but they bent us over
they made us come into their [ __ ]
offices they bent us over a table and
they shoved [ __ ] in our eyes i think
they think all american people look
alike
and they're like oh we don't know i
think i'm confused about that
maybe chinese people are like oh all
americans look alike to us too
you know white people no no chinese
people look alike
but i don't understand what th what you
mean they didn't know they were
diplomats maybe we saw these some
regular
you know american jokes no they're
saying they shouldn't have done it at
all yeah the anal swab thing oh no they
were anal swabbing mad people and then
when the diplomats came
oh i see what you're saying they were
like oh we didn't know that they
they were supposed to get a different
security where are they sure they didn't
swap their own too
look they don't care what you do to your
own you're not gonna stick nothing in an
american's [ __ ]
they already did yeah they did yeah they
didn't do that you don't get in our
proverbial
dead ass if biden put a nuke off
right now and it was like well they were
sticking things in our ass you were in a
little party you'd be like that's my
[ __ ] guy
that's my [ __ ] we get nuked
right back nah they can't reach us bro
they reach us bro
how do they go reach us they built they
have a billion of them like ants they'll
build a bridge
to a place where they can [ __ ] launch
it they will build a human bridge
yeah i think we can nuke them first dude
have you ever seen them [ __ ] do like
uh you know [ __ ]
dance dance revolution they know how to
hook on to each other oh yeah yeah
they [ __ ] hook on to each other they
can plug in like they're magical people
they can plug into each other
they do the ass and they do a human
centipede like that they build a bridge
and they'll launch it close
but what are they going to launch it off
of offer the [ __ ] last dude who's
hanging off the bridge
you're going to launch a nuke right off
the last year yeah dude they're [ __ ]
they're tricky like that man they named
it they named it tick tock because
they're [ __ ] with us too they're it's
called tick-tock because they know
we're at our end what's up they're going
tik-tok america
dude taiwan they took [ __ ] honk
our economy is collapsing pretty soon
american women are going to move to
china to open [ __ ] nail salons it's
over
it's a reversal of it's a reversal of
destiny
oh yeah they're going to be in there
going five dollar five dollars
and then the chinese are going to be
there's going to be some chinese comic
was going to go viral going have you
ever gone into an american store they go
five dollars
they pronounce their ours they're
[ __ ] weird
i think they're talking [ __ ] about us in
their own language there will be a
chinese angela johnson who and then
there'll be a bunch of comments going
she's not that funny but she'll be
making millions of dollars
there'll be a reversal of rose really
yeah they [ __ ] let's move there and
surrender dude it's
no don't you want to fight back honestly
no i want to learn how to talk their
language i want to learn
you're never gonna that [ __ ] is too
complicated just make noises and [ __ ]
learn how to do puzzles
if you could solve a [ __ ] stick and
adopt puzzles you can speak it
didn't we just have a 30-minute
conversation about how you only want to
do what you want to do
and the second chinese i want to go
right i'll learn mandarin
[ __ ] it let's do puzzles sudoku great
dude they already have taken over
nah bro they've taken over nukes the
only problem
is nukes we got noobs but you can't you
can't you can't you gotta start with a
littler china
no you just gotta go in dude vietnam run
it back
the sequel yeah
not for real dude i'm not i'm not
bending over man you have enough of that
yeah enough of that dude yeah but why
are you so willing
because they won no they didn't win
how'd they win they sent corona they let
us know who's boss they let us know
who's boss
trump was like i'm going to put all
these tariffs we're going to [ __ ]
they're like oh yeah
and then they just flick virus into the
west yeah and just like
they were party did you see times square
their equivalent to times square called
in wuhan where they
yeah it comes from like their language
comes from like somewhere
yeah and uh do you see what they were
doing that's how you sounded with corona
was like i'm trying to do it i'm trying
to get you i'm trying to get we've got
four nurses in the area they won't go up
there i'm talking to shelters i grew up
with children where my best friends
don't do anything for them
now what do you mean what do you need
have you tried the chicken soup that's
what my grandmother used to do just take
chicken soup you're going to be okay
okay
you're going to be fine did you get this
from makasha no you got to stay away
from those people there's a lot of
diseases
that part of the world they don't wash
their hands they kill rats with their
hands
oh my god you ever seen those you ever
watch the documentary rats
like they go to england in india and
there's just a dude in the street
killing them with their hands
you saw him call it i almost called it
england
downhill from there you know okay no
so you really are ready to bend over for
china you would let them swap you over
no no you would let them anal swab you
yeah
over there and they're like bend over
it's time for your anal swab and you
would say okay and take it so [ __ ]
literally
i'm ready i think they're despicable
dude i'm ready
you took a show at netflix after you
said netflix was over and you're calling
me despicable hey hey hey
ferrari or a board
we driving big [ __ ] baby
you know miami is the only [ __ ] city
where you'll see like a purple
lamborghini
outside of a restaurant and then you'll
see you'll go follow that dude
in that purple language like where does
he live he lives with his mom
he lives with his mom or he just sleep
in the lamborghini that yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's why i'm getting a fake car
though yeah
what do you mean i'm gonna get a fake
one what do you mean a fake one
i'm gonna buy a fake car from china
no not from china american made yeah
german cars
no yeah american cars are fake cars yeah
no but for real i'm gonna buy a fake one
i looked it up so i want like this 1965
porsche right it's a speedster yeah and
they happen to be like three hundred
thousand dollars when they're real
and then this but this guy tells me he
goes no you can get like a replica of it
and i go what's that he goes
yeah some a company that's reputable
just builds a new version of it
and then you put a new engine in yeah
and like new parts and stuff you can
actually have like ac and like power
windows
but the shell looks like the old porsche
that you like maybe it's 1956 or
something like that right
and i was like yeah i was gonna do all
that to it anyway
there's no way i'm paying three hundred
thousand dollars for a car i was like
how much is that i think it's gonna be
like
200 or 100. they're like oh you can
probably get down for like 40 000. i'm
like hold up
i can have the car that looks the way i
want it to look
with all the new [ __ ] because there's no
way i'm going to be driving my [ __ ]
wife around with 1950s brakes
like would you put your girl this
pregnant in a car with 1950s breaking
definitely not
you gonna upgrade all this [ __ ] anyway i
was like sway i can get the thing i'm
not a [ __ ] car enthusiast right i
just want the [ __ ] to look beautiful
because they look you're beautiful they
made these beautiful cars back in the
day right i was like
there's no way in hell i'm gonna spend
top dollar when it's not even the [ __ ] i
want
right i'm not trying to impress some
like [ __ ] loser that's into cars
right i'm trying to press the guy that
knows nothing about cars
but hell yeah so i'm gonna get my kit
card it's called a kit car nice
yeah yeah i didn't even know you could
do that 100 i don't think you can do it
like the
like if for example you get like an old
ferrari or something like that you might
want to get the actual car
yeah but like from the 1950s a [ __ ]
porsche yeah dude i mean that's a german
car i can't
support 1950s germany yeah yeah well
they had cleaned it up by then
yeah but it was still lingering it's not
like you like stop being hateful
no they stop they i think they got the
message yeah
they got the message but it didn't go
away it's not like they saw like
jewish people and they're like the wall
was do it the wall was still up
but they were commuting yeah but that's
different communist yeah but you think
they look just we're just like nah these
are cool now like you think that you
could play
but i could i would buy a car they
pretended they got worse about it i
think that's german that would
be the equivalent of awokeness though
like if there was a social media germans
would be like here's me with my jewish
friend
yeah now but not 1950s immediately 50s
they tried to they tried to clean it up
quick
you think you can just snap out i think
germany firebomb the [ __ ] out of dresden
people don't know that like because it
didn't have the big bang that uh
you know that we did in uh hiroshima but
we
[ __ ] carpet bombed those snow monkeys
i mean we [ __ ] carpet bombed them i
mean we killed a lot
of german we sent a message yeah we said
don't [ __ ] with the boys you got us
involved we were [ __ ] doing our thing
playing baseball now we're coming over
here
and showing you what it means we can't
do that to china you too scared bro
we can't bro you're scared bro you got
too many of them bro
no they don't you gotta back we have
nukes you just wipe them out
austin girls got to eat look at us we're
we don't want to be soldiers bro i know
i was scared of corona you think i'm
going to war i would do it bro i would
do it you ain't doing nothing i would do
it i saw 911 i was like i'm gonna let
the boys handle that
yeah but when i saw anal swabs when i
saw china [ __ ] anal swab u.s
diplomats
it's time to go here's the red button
here's the thing let's go
biden you got a decent you're decent
with moving hands around i seen you
yeah but if you got a hundred you know
the movies ain't real bro
like if a hundred of them come at you
bro yeah bro hop on you
i'm just in miami bro i'm going oh miami
bro
yo bro yo hello bro what happened what
happened
like godzilla like a hundred of them
will just [ __ ] climb on you and
slowly take you down
yeah yeah they will slowly overwhelm you
yeah like you ever see like a bunch of
bees trying to get like a wasp that goes
in there and [ __ ] when it beads up and
then they they try you get try
you can try to get close to the queen
yeah they'll swarm you what are you not
getting about
nukes they that they have them too no
but they don't go far enough
how do you know bro are you in the
military yes i know about these things
it's because the earth spins the other
way yeah you got to go the other way
stupid yo bro
they're all ready you don't you don't
think they got nukes in chinatown
they've been colonizing us
for years wow they're trying to tell you
they got sleeper cells in chinatown
also if anybody's listening to this
please do not uh you know
do any acts of violence on asian america
no do not absolutely
jokes please just jokes we're joking
around now
chinese chinese people like from china
this is what it is
on my behalf
you